depuis la mise en service du
téléphérique qu'ils ont baptisé le
tramway du ciel les habitants de
roosevelt island mais exactement cinq
minutes à l'aller pour se rendre à
manhattan
et autant le soir pour rentrer chez eux
new york est doté d'un téléphérique
urbain c'est une première aux états unis
une première dont n'ont pourtant pas à
rougir les français chez nous le premier
téléphérique urbain est apparu bien
avant c'était à grenoble en 1934
ce que j'aime de grenoble séquelles à la
physionomie d'une ville et non pas d'un
grand village
ce jugement de stendhal sur sa ville
natale et vérifier dès que l'on emprunte
le téléphérique pour monter à la
bastille en 1976 la ville moderniser
inauguré son nouveau téléphérique urbain
non sans difficulté tout fonctionnait
normalement et puis brusquement vers 16h
le câble porteur sautent des roues du
treuil immobilisant les bulles à 270
mètres de hauteur au-dessus de grenoble
après grenoble
le téléphérique urbain ne fait plus
parler de lui ce mode de transport est
concurrencé par le métro et le bus au
début des années 2010 l'idée d'en
construire à nouveau refait surface
alors que l'écologie est devenue un
enjeu majeur en 2013
un projet de téléphérique urbain à
créteil étaient à l'étude pour les
jeunes pour la créteil centre commercial
où joue au foot ou pour profiter des
installations sportives de créteil très
bien aujourd'hui encore le projet de
téléphérique urbain à créteil est en
stand by au contraire de brest en 2016
la ville adopté ce mode de transport
une première en france depuis grenoble
ce téléphérique urbain peut alors
transporter jusqu'à 1200 personnes par
heure
si le maire a opté pour la voie des airs
à plus de 30 mètres de hauteur c'est
pour décongestionner les rues de sa
ville
mais c'est aussi parce que c'est
beaucoup moins cher qu'un nouveau pont
les coûts sont non non rien à voir un
pont
ça aurait été d'être vincent millions
d'euros donc on n'est pas là c'est
distincts millions d'euros on n'est pas
dans la même configuration
malgré un avenir prometteur ce mode de
transport peu aussi rencontré quelques
problèmes
quelques jours seulement après son
inauguration le téléphérique urbain de
brest était déjà à l'arrêt à 50 mètres
de haut
les portes du téléphérique s'ouvre
brusquement donnant droit sur lapin feld
abord un technicien qui effectue un
voyage de vérification échappe au pire
après grenoble en 1934 et brest en 2016
c'est au tour de toulouse de se munir de
son téléphérique urbain
il devrait voir le jour à la fin de
l'année 2020
[Musique]